Вітаю Олексію Розкажіть будь ласочка З
чим ви приїхали і до кого мені дуже
приємно що сьогодні в Одесі Петро
Олексійович Порошенко і він як завжди
приїжджає не з пустими руками він привіз
пікап для новоствореної бригади ПВО Ну і
безумовно зараз для Одеси ПВО це взагалі
така топ-тема ви бачите як Путін
намагається стерти з лиця землі наше
місто історичний центр внесений в Юнеско
порт від якого залежить життя сотень
мільйонів людей по всьому світу тому що
це головний ворота для українського
аграрного експорту Тому це надзвичайно
важливе питання для Одеси і для України
через в Одесі як настрої людей і взагалі
в якому все стані після такого страшного
останнього обстрілу ну дивіться
безумовно такий тиждень який був він був
дуже складний це виматує але з іншого
боку одесити то одесити ми абсолютно не
опускаємо голову як знаєте от я прийшов
ранок після цього страшного
найстрашнішого обстрілу по центру міста
і Там значить така стояла в автомобіль
біля зруйнованого пам'ятки пам'ятники
архітектури в сусідньому пам'ятнику
пошкодженому живе людина а поруч був
припаркований його автомобіль І в цей
автомобіль був просто наскрізь
проткнутий арматурою яка злетіла з того
з цієї будівлі і наскрі спротнула Ну я
Це доволі жахливо виглядає Коли я це
побачив я побачив власника я Він
сміється Я кажу що що ви смієтесь він
каже ну Слава Богу Я живий я що то
машина це таке я кажу Ну що як у вас
настрій зараз він каже настрій такий Щоб
дістати цю арматуру і засунути Путіну в
дупу оце настрій одеситів ми місто герої
ми
Південна столиця України ми
військово-морська столиця України нас не
налякати Але звичайно цього покидька
треба зупиняти
роботи останнього в Верховній Раді після
цих всіх мальдівських скандалів як
взагалі
як взагалі там настрої серед ваших колег
це хороше питання Ну мені здається що
для багато хто і це ми черговий раз
засвідчились вже Забули що в країні де
війна живуть своїм життям вирішують
власні питання Ну і це взагалі якесь
божевілля Виявляється що виїхати за
кордон не можна тільки тим хто є як в
опозицію Хоча всі якомога всі
підтримуємо
перемогу але от наприклад і мені вже
декілька разів не дали можливості
виїхати в тому числі на заходи в
парламентської асамблеї Ради Європи на
офіційне спостереження виборів Туреччині
надзвичайно важливий для нас країни а
виявляється що це тільки в мене такі
проблеми А в інших проблем нема
виїжджають куди хочуть як хочуть
відпочивають все це дуже ганебно коли
люди бачать ці серіали барабани тайланди
відпочинки і все інше то це
для людей свідчення того що Ну от ті хто
сидять в Верховній Раді багато хто
забули чим вони реально мають займатися
і те як склад де оту боротьба яку там Я
веду за відпустки за доплати за все все
все воно демонструє що вони просто
навіть Ну знаєте підзабули що якщо
незброєнні сили України і якщо ми не
будемо працювати кожен день на нашу
перемогу то ну В нас просто не буде
країни тому будемо їм про це нагадувати
і будемо добиватися щоби парламент
працював на перемогу і на державу дякую
вам